hello and welcome to this video playing
Mark Smith okay said mark a smith from
the follower okay not the real real mom
is probably okay I'm declining the bank
or whatever he is after I probably the
Benoni I'd still decline it let's just
play some different kind of position
okay well covering this is usually not a
great idea anyway so let's see I'm here
many moves are possible Fisher therefore
i think is one of them going for
compensation for the pawn yeah just
going back
yeah this is a this line is known and
been various shapes and forms I mean
grabbing on on before you black can do
that in in various ways and it's always
slightly slightly risky I've played some
games with that myself and blitz and
often got into trouble okay so okay but
if i go back to e3 the Queen has no
square right well see forward it's not a
very safe looking square
III like a 324 Roxy one it's got no
worry in the world now probably he's got
some very spit some 95 is the threat hmm
still I thought 95 or I see what is he
doing giving the queen or maybe I don't
know Queen 86 97 is pretty good still
the queen is trapped yeah so he's giving
the Queen so what does he have he's got
queen and he's got the rook and wicked
Knight and porner look night pond well
that's it I mean it shouldn't be enough
but it's usually good enough to UM to
play I mean it's not just lost or
anything try to and get an immediate
attack going 493 g5 this kind of thing
cannot take be too yeah okay
five is not so convincing actually very
Queen h5 still shooting for an attack
yeah i was thinking this and try to try
to get the bishop to deform i have to
make sure that i'm not getting mcqueen
tractor that can can happen easily k so
not age for for example it's not a good
idea um maybe Knight f3
crying for Bishop g4 push okay for right
now it's not easy for him now to defend
I don't see a defense to be honest takes
a three-row care three that's made on g7
so it cannot take g5 ok so here if I
take 95 95 this Bishop b5 95 this Bishop
g5
I have not you for though this is a neat
195 Bishop g5 night you for and to take
tonight h6 made okay that's nice
and if you change bishop takes is made
on g7
I wonder if Knight takes g6 is
technically stronger
Nyjah forwards the move that I was it
has so on yeah I think it's okay
we should age 69 h6 mate checkmate yeah
it's a head skewed okay so he probably
had to do something roughly here I mean
that the queen is in danger oh it's
already lost surprising after castles
it's lost cool okay so he had to play
Knight a5 it's what the engine is giving
92 castles Chum and now the computer
wants to play Queen to see one with an
equal position jumped tough yeah the
computer gives white compensation you
haven't 96 yeah this is the kind of
position you get its white has an
initiative but things are not clear at
all okay castles a 3 here and in fact
this isn't the best move played it very
quickly 92 is stronger okay this this
and Bishop f1 okay it's cool here pretty
strapped with Bishop f1 you can try this
but I have this move and then Bishop
everyone next very nice so that wasn't
good it wasn't the best okay our blogs
defense it's not very easy neji for its
that that's what is so could have done
let your phone now that's very okay for
black 95 this is a much better version
of the Queen sacrifice as here my one
structure is totally damaged
so this what's best Bishop f4 huh I it
looks very dangerous for black intern
probably objectively also bad but still
very tricky 995 and again yeah it's a
it's one of those Queen sex however this
is very good for white it's very similar
action to the to the game I think that
blacks coordination is not good at love
here this is this is very dangerous for
black and the Angelus is giving why the
win neither five was already possible
but I think this is a good way of
playing yeah this is most nice well not
f7 is technically the strongest okay now
that it doesn't matter is also just a
total wind he was nice enough to allow
me that static made okay interesting
game thanks for watching